oh my God oh my
God oh my
God small I don't know how health ftic
you are but this is some this video was
sponsored by Muslim M inah to build
confidence and speak brother sisters
confidence is very important confidence
was one of the things that led me to
Islam not my own confidence but the
confidence of Zak ahed as the confidence
that he had in his religion made me
realize why is he so sure about what he
speaking and he made me listen to him
attentively so guys when it comes to
confidence and how to speak you need
this in marriage work colleagues friends
giving da so brother sisters many diet
have also taken this course inah please
check in the link below let's get
straight to the
video brothers and sisters and dear
friends I came across a video on
Instagram um of sister Aisha Mercedes um
her mom reacting her mom's a non-muslim
um reacting to muy M so here's a video
we're going to watch for our in I find
it very profound because a lot of the
times when it comes to Da and how we
make Islam look uh we some think it's
about how much Quran you know how much
you recite Etc but it boils actually
back down to how one carries himself and
character and the prophet said so much
important stuff about this so here's the
video we're going to be reacting where M
surprises aa's mother who's a non-muslim
who's watching the videos and let's see
what we can take from this because I
think there's some really important
reminders in so here is the video let's
get into it in he super a long time
because stop it but I don't know if I
kept that one he was really really young
but you said you joined the group didn't
you yeah he said about temper there was
one on there I kept it controlling your
temper not get angry or something which
I thought that'd be good for you
me where did you come across myy M you
just popped up I get a lot of things
because of you myy m though myy M
noty yeah he's really he's really good
he's got a good like personality he fun
with it and stuff yeah you see i' hate
to people straight away otherwise not
yeah so he's one of those people people
like him the way he tells whatever he's
telling it would attract a people I
would think it definitely does me I
would listen to him there's a lot I hear
and I think yeah you're probably talking
sense but not many of them would I
listen to No matter what we're talking
about I like the way he it's simple it's
not like can't understand like he's
talking so much speak long words that I
can't understand or he's talking but
he's very very full of people talking
like everybody could understand and he
sounds very genuine to me and believes
in what he's saying he's not just
preaching it he's explaining things so
anything of his that comes on I like to
listen
oh amazing nice to see
[Music]
you oh my gosh and you know I'm not
obviously but I really find the way you
talk how do you become how do you get
so
openminded and wise yeah that's it yeah
how do you get like that because I I
have watched quite a few people and I
haven't really they haven't stood out
for me you know to be honest with you
there are there are a few there are
quite a lot but each person's
temperament is different so maybe what
you saying perhaps there is some form of
a connection between us I don't mean you
know it's attractive it kind
of the way you say things it's
believable it's so hits me like yeah I
could listen to this person I'm really
fussy about you know cuz not everyone
tells the truth not everyone talks
things and we all make mistakes
sometimes I have to improve on some of
the uh maybe some of the stuff Within
Myself I'm relatively stri person I
follow my faith quite strictly but we
have to put ourselves in the shoes of
others when we're talking to and we
can't really preach down on
someone okay guys so that was pleasant
to see because at the end of the day I
have non-muslim family members um and if
I mean I I I would be really happy if I
mean if my dad was to watch someone
that's an Islamic influence or whatever
which he doesn't but if he was like you
know touched by somewhere was like you
know what okay look I have my opinions
about Islam and whatever it is but this
one person yeah you know I would I would
try my best to get that person at all
cost to speak to my dad because to me
that's like maybe that is the missing
key to my dad accepting Islam or any
other family member for that matter so
to me me I would have done exactly the
same thing so we hope this means that
she accepts Islam but there's a few
things we need to understand because the
prophet mammed said I came for nothing
but a perfect good character I recommend
one book it's quite big it's from imari
when it comes to it's called it talks
about the and maners of your dealings
with variety of things yes and it's so
important because many times we are told
that a person of good etiquet good so
this is so profound Subhan Allah a
person who be
fasting extra fasting and doing all the
extra stuff but has ill manners will
enter the fire they can and a person who
does the basics but had good good
manners would enter Jenna the prophet
said the two things that be heavy on
your are and one's good maners what does
good manners mean this is where we don't
understand good maners is not saying oh
please thank you how are you no the
prophet had the most utmost brilliant
character so much so it was an evidence
to the being sent to him it has to be an
Evidence why because people are like how
could it be this person who doesn't
likee his character is so amazing that's
why when he got the Revelation and he
came down he said cover me cover me I
don't know what's going on said what he
said for you you do not break kinship
you feed the orphan the poor he said
Allah Will Never Let You Down do you see
how she connected his character his the
way he car him carries himself to Allah
has got your back this is so important
in today's time you have Muslims who
pray who read Quran who wear hijab who
grow beard who wear th Etc you look at
the and it's got nothing to do with
Islam bro it's so far away from Islam
and then you look at certain non-muslims
you look at the ad and character you
think to yourself like if this person
became a Muslim wow amazing that's why
manners are so profound and how does one
start manners you start to have good
manners with Allah by not associating
Partners to him by not seeing Allah has
a son Allah is one of the Trinity Allah
this Allah that or like the qu said
Allah has daughters why cuz they saw
daughters as inferior they said the
angels of Allah are daughters this is
having ill bad manage with Allah subhana
wa tala having good maners with Allah is
what you obey him you say he is one and
you worship him that's good maners with
Allah how do you have good manners with
who's after that the the prophet mammad
Sall alhi wasallam by saying sallallah
alaih wasallam is showing you good
manage to the message of Allah sallam
that you follow his Sunnah not yeah it's
Quran only muslimah whatever it is no
you follow his Sunnah you try to abide
by his sunah to the best of your ability
then who do you have good maners with
your community at large your neighbors
when is the last time you checked on
your neighbors when is the last time you
went to your neighbors and said do you
need something an elderly neighbor do
who want to do shopping for you w
Indonesia I think it's Indonesia one of
the biggest populated Muslim countries
you know how they came to Islam they
came to Islam via Yemen traders who
would go and trade with them and they
were so upholders of honesty in
transaction so honest and not cheating
people it was a ripple effect of people
coming to Islam people look at your
actions they don't care what you say bro
how good you you speak so and then after
that one's good manages with their self
when you are committing sin how's my
relationship with the Quran I'm
committing major sins I'm drinking
alcohol I'm committing Zena I'm gambling
I'm doing this I'm B in my spouse I'm
bad to my brother I'm bad to my mom you
see to yourself is this good maners
Within Myself good manage is what that's
what Allah says the ones have seen one
who they wrong theirself how do you
wrong Yourself by having ill manage with
yourself so all I want to say says to
wrap up on this in is I am happy may
Allah subhana guide her mother insh
because at the end of the day I know how
it is to have a parent that's a
non-muslim and you scared if they die in
that I'm not going to make Dua for them
whatever it is for that matter I
understand that I I truly relate to that
so the full video is on sister A's
Channel you can go check that inah but
in the meantime Brother and Sisters
Let's have good maners good good in and
may Allah subhana tala bless M and the
works that he's doing and forgive him
for the shortcomings that we all do
inshallah and that's what I want to say
and make Dua for the sister's mother in
she accept and for all of us and my
father as well that's all I want to say
in may Allah make us uphold this of good
and good that people see Islam in US
rather than hear itam